Android patterns for performance
External libraries may provide important time savings.
It allows us to do great things about our application
Without having to write any posts by ourselves,
This is a very big benefit.
But the useless thing is to inflate the code.
I'm David East.
You can easily get everything you need from a library
Without inflating the code.
But to go back a step back.
If you're creating an easy-to-use, high-performance mobile app
With a small team and perhaps a small budget,
You may be using a lot of external Android libraries
To help you with the difficult things.
This is fine.
It is actually a good idea.
Many libraries have undergone several tests
And proved its ability to handle production pressure.
But the problem is
You may have to import the entire library
When you plan to use only a subset.
The result is called "code inflation".
Additional code paths are converted to push-ups with APK,
The code inflates is a serious issue.
At its simplest level, increase the size of your compiled code.
This amplifies the APK package that the user should download.
The most disturbing thing is the alarming 65k limit.
Android time assigns a digital ID
For each method.
This ID is 16 bits.
So if you have more than 2 to 16 methods in your app,
It will not be aggregated.
The only way to avoid this is to solve the new MultiDex.
You do not need that, believe me.
They are as fun as going to a dentist.
Fortunately, there is a tool among the Android Toolkit
It is great at locating unused code
And removed from the release.
Proguard is a tool
Reduce, improve, and hide your code instructions by removing unused parts.
It also renames categories, fields, and styles
With uncommon names
To reverse the code reverse geometrically.
But let's take this in another video.
Proguard is a very wonderful tool.
Take a look at the Google I / O 2015 app.
It is a great application with lots of functions
Which use multiple shared libraries.
When you create a version without shrinking Proguard for the code,
It will produce about 8.4 megabytes of code.
But with Proguard, only 4.1 results.
This is very cool because of how easy it is to set up and shrink this code.
To run the ProGuard shrink code
All you have to do is set Minify Enabled to "True" in the Gradle settings.
Then, when you create your app,
All unused code will be removed for you.
But Proguard is not perfect.
Despite its remarkable performance in detecting most uses,
Its performance is not as good as screening other cases,
Such as the code used for reflection.
This may lead to false positive results;
Some code is removed and some are left,
Which means that you will have to adjust Proguard settings
Based on listed libraries.
Some may require special rules
To ensure things work properly.
So plan for your future well and look at the documents.
Go to developer.android.com
Read ProGuard Official Documents.
Without joking, go and read all that.
I think it is suitable for reading before bedtime.
When you finish reading all the documents or taking a nap,
Count and watch other Android Performance Patterns videos.
Do not miss joining the Google+ community
Share your tips on Proguard with other developers.
Consider small things but do not panic.
Always remember that performance is important.